joining me now is president Trump's
personal attorney Bobby Giuliani and saw
Weisenberger former deputy independent
counsel and Fox News contributor all
right Rudy sue Bologna also is saying
that the Muller reports makes their
requests moot your reaction of that diss
Congress well for very right to this
information at all let me let me say
something about Natalie's response that
the president is a tyrant and above the
law this is a legal memorandum and Jerry
might have a hard time understanding
because he's not much of a lawyer but
it's a legal memorandum it's very well
thought out very well-written obviously
it makes the point of executive
privilege but it goes way beyond
executive privilege it makes a very very
important point I would have added
Pelosi statement last week that the
legislature is the superior branch
because that's the way they're acting
they have issued not just they have not
just one hearing they have six hearings
so it has to be seen in the context of
six hearings they are they have already
issued hundreds of subpoenas looking for
possibly a million documents or more and
we have natla we have shift we have
comings they're all kind of like want
you know daytime television time and the
reality is this is a this is a
tremendous burden on the executive and
the law has a way to deal with it there
are cases that say that legislative
power is there but it can't be used for
an impermissible it has to be a proper
legislative purpose in their subpoena is
their information requests they don't
cite a single piece of legislation
they're pursuing not only that they are
taking over an executive branch function
and they're afraid to call this a
impeachment hearing so this is oversight
you don't issue hundreds of offenders
yeah hold on so are you saying that if
this were actually an impeachment
proceeding you wouldn't have any problem
with no I'm with it because they really
have to generate their own information
they can't be just redoing that and if
they were in good faith they they would
read through the mower report and they
would say we now have all this
formation we have ten more questions or
15 more questions well there are in fact
doing a dramatic reading I think of the
wealthy exactly
several recent federal cases make it
clear that if you're going to impose on
the executive it has to be tailored it
has to be narrow it can't be overly
intrusive this is all those things it's
overly intrusive it's completely
burdensome it is not only do positive
it's multiplied by six well this isn't
even talking about the case that's in
the DC District Court now involving the
president's financial records which
they're also arguing in front of another
Obama appoint I think they have to be at
the court you have to argue these as one
because as they affect the executive
branch they are not six separate
hearings you've got a recent you have to
respond to this avalanche of subpoenas
which means you've got a comment down
shop yeah it's meant to paralyze I gotta
get to saw a former Justice Department
official says that the White House's
assertion that Congress does not have a
right to the information is mind-blowing
this is Joshua Joshua gelts are saying
these aren't peripheral interests of the
US Congress their core oversight
responsibilities at the heart of our
legislative branch checking our
executive branch and even just
understanding it how do you react to
that well I think both sides have a
problem I think that the subpoenas have
been grossly over broad coming from the
House of Representatives I also think
the letter from the White House Counsel
is is very over broad there really is no
such thing as saying constitutionally is
saying you don't get to do a do-over and
congressional authority to investigate
is very very broad but Laura these
battles have gone back to the beginning
of the Republic go back to 1796 Congress
wanted all of President Washington's
papers related to the Jay Treaty and
Washington said you're not going to get
him and James Madison said we as the
Congress a congressman we have the right
to anything we asked for but the
president has a right to say I don't
want to give it to you and this is part
of the checks and balances and it'll be
very interesting to see how it works out
yeah we're going beyond perhaps the
unitary executive here to something the
left is saying I mean dana Milbank has
this piece out saying this is this is
basically they're trying to
they have a divine right to the
informational Milbank's a big liberal
but but they were always jockeying for
power Rudy I mean you remember this the
days when you weren't the J it's always
a fight between the legislative branch
and the executive branch but I have
never seen it like I see it now
with this president I think every turn
they have hounded him at every turn and
they've accused him of sedition being a
traitor Tyrod setting up meetings at
Trump Tower made a tyrant okay but this
is it he's like a combo they say a pulp
pot Stalin and and Chairman Mao or
something I mean this is this is this is
the level of it but I want to I want to
play something that Jerry Nadler said
tonight actually because he was reacting
to the administration's response over at
MSNBC let's watch we are looking at all
options to deal with the lawless
administration and everything is being
looked at everything is being looked at
including including possible jail we're
looking at the law but we will look at
all options to force to force the
administration to hope to be able to
hold the administration accountable
whatever they may take okay that was
obviously but Rudy what is he talking
about here what what are the remedies
here they have to be a judicial remedy
they're going to arrest somebody gonna
get US Marshals to come arrest what let
me let me try to respond to is rather an
articulate comment I think he's saying
he would look at jail which is of course
absurd there's nothing lawless about the
administration's response salt could be
quite right that it's a very broad
response but you know as a lawyer you
raise all your arguments I think there
is some that are over broad and I think
there is some that are very very strong
the strongest one being that in the
Cheney case the court held that the
power of the Congress is very broad but
not unlimited and I think given the
number of subpoenas given the number of
hearings given the already predetermined
positions of the three chairmen who have
already said he should be impeached and
Natalja was overheard planning it on
Amtrak I think that they've got a very
good are
to the court how did things ever get
this far and let's check this a little
as long as they're willing to compromise
as long as they're willing to compromise
if there's going to be a narrower more
focused on Maloney he left the door open
so it's not like he's shutting the door
company leaving that's right so we then
responds it's not me Ellis I'm gonna go
before report and I like an argument
whom they don't want to go before that
they don't want to pay full you know
what yeah well I want to play something
because all this goes into what we were
talking about last week also Rudy there
there's a brewing fight going on it
looks like between Brennan and call me
when it comes to the use of this phony
dossier Catherine Herridge reported on
this earlier a dispute over whether
former CIA director John Brennan or
former FBI director James Comey pushed
the unverified dossier during the
presidential transition has broken out
into the open the records are not public
but sources familiar with the contents
say December 2016 emails indicate Comey
told bureau subordinates that Brennan
insisted that dossier should be included
in the formal intelligence assessment on
Russian election interference well I'm
hearing one of those communications
they're talking about also says that Jim
Comey in December of 2016 said the
dossier is unreliable he didn't want the
Intel Intel to review it we hear tonight
I heard today from a high place White
House source that the president it may
be looking to release and declassify all
the relevant documents leading up to
start of the Russia probe next week but
he's gonna but I heard he's gonna give
him to attorney general Barr to review
well I've been hearing that for a long
time apparently it's next week
well my source tells me that'll be
interesting and that'll give us a lot of
answers here debating this this will
we'll have a lot more answers we'll have
actual facts on the table right yeah and
Kobe admits in his own book that he you
know he didn't reveal the whole the
whole dossier to the president only the
salacious parts he didn't tell him that
there was this investigation that had
been going on I mean that's in his own
book so I don't I don't want to
speculate on
those two which one is right and Rudi
apparently there was some talk about how
this would look this could look like
among Intel sources that it could look
like the FBI was doing some kind of
weird
preemptive blackmail with the president
and it called me going to that meeting
that just it didn't look good they were
worried about this that call me
presenting this dossier a part of it to
the president would look like he was
kind of having some J Edgar Hoover
tactics against the president that is
really disturbing it finally look like
it it was I mean the reality is that
kill me is the noose is tightening
around his neck really bad call me in
January told the president it was
salacious unverified how did it become
salacious and unverified over five
months when they used it in affidavits
in which Comey says on the top of the
affidavit that it's verified in footnote
5 page 15 he says it's reliable not
unverified nothing was he either lied to
the president or he lied to the court
I'm betting on he lied to the court we
call that perjury Jim and Brennan may be
a witness against you
that'd be interesting I know it's hard
to indict Cardinal this is going to get
Guymon just next week
this guy can tell you what's gonna
happen to your immortal soul which he
said to rod Rosenstein about rod Rosen's
in the other day yeah so maybe he's
above indictment I don't know he's he's
back in the redwoods tonight alright
guys thanks so much